Phoenix: Hi. My name is Phoenix, and I'm a tester for fable. Today we are going to be working on Sgt. Tracking your expenses with money manager 3
Phoenix: UOC. I'd dash RCLL. 1 0.
Phoenix: So today we are just going to be looking at a money manager. App. It is a budgeting tool. So we'll be going through and setting up a couple of expense categories and adding an income
Phoenix: and looking at a few different areas to kind of get a sense of
Phoenix: an overall budget. You know, how much is everything actually costing us?
Phoenix: We're just going to take an overall look at this app and
Phoenix: you know, check out a few different things and talk about
Phoenix: how accessible it is. What could be improved, what's done? Well, and with that being said, we're going to go ahead and get started. I am on the homepage of the money manager. App
Phoenix: and I'm at the top of the screen. And the so the first thing that we're gonna do is kind of explore the app and get a feel for it after we've gotten a feel for it. Then I will go in and create some expense categories.
Phoenix: So I'm just going to start by swiping to the right.
Phoenix: Okay. apologies. I just needed to make sure I was at the top.
Awesome.
Phoenix: Okay? Excellent. I don't know.
Phoenix: But I guess I'm fine. No matter. Okay, and that annotation is just zoom controls at the bottom, so it has nothing to do with the app.
Phoenix: So
Phoenix: since I want to create some expense categories, let me let me check and see
awesome.
Phoenix: Okay? So maybe I'll try double tapping where it says category name
Phoenix: at this point at this point. and that didn't really seem to do anything
Phoenix: and morning. Watch this.
Oh, my telephone.
Phoenix: Let's see. Maybe I need to check out this main menu and see if creating a category is in this. So let's double tap on the
Phoenix: open menu and and yeah, I'm sorry. Okay, I'll just. I'm sorry. Alright, let's try double tapping on budget categories.
Phoenix: Okay, not fun. Okay, not just fine morning.
Awesome.
Phoenix: I mean, okay.
Phoenix: So this unlabeled button I'm going to guess is an Add button for a category. Let me go ahead and try double tapping on that, and just see if it is
Phoenix: okay. Okay. So
Phoenix: the first thing to note is that it would be really, really important to add some text to that unlabeled button that says, add category. Just so, you know, people are aware of what this button does.
Phoenix: But with that being said, let's go ahead and type in a category name.
Phoenix: That's great.
Phoenix: We will do food.
Phoenix: Take that up.
Phoenix: It is
Phoenix: morning awesome. Oh, it didn't type my characters.
Phoenix: Sorry. Let me try that again.
you know. Okay, okay.
Phoenix: that was 100% user error. It had nothing to do with the the app. I forgot that I'm supposed to double tap instead of tap and hold on this keyboard to type in my characters. So let's keep exploring this window.
Phoenix: It is to be my husband. I'm late at this point.
Phoenix: We're not gonna leave it until we can.
Phoenix: Okay, we're going to give ourselves a budget of, let's say, 500
Phoenix: 24 pulled up by
Phoenix: okay.
Phoenix: continue exploring the screen. I guess I need to add my income will try double tapping on this button and see what it does.
Phoenix: Okay.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Phoenix: Okay, so I think that label might have been a little bit misleading because it says, add income, but when you double tap on it, it appears to just
Phoenix: save your category. So perhaps renaming the label to save instead of add income. But we will go ahead and create a second category. Now.
Phoenix: I'm sorry.
Phoenix: All right, we will call this one.
Phoenix: That's great bills deep like pulling up.
Yup.
Okay.
Phoenix: yes, dear.
Phoenix: I don't like.
Phoenix: I don't. But wait a minute.
Phoenix: Okay, then we're gonna write the maximum amount we can spend in this category. We're gonna assume that we've got pretty high bills. So let's do $1,500
Phoenix: number 4.
Phoenix: Maybe I can find the one.
Phoenix: Let me double check and make sure. I wrote that number right?
Phoenix: Test one. I guess I got them.
Phoenix: So we'll double tap on this. Add income button again.
Phoenix: Okay, so that's
Phoenix: morning.
Phoenix: bye, bye.
Phoenix: Okay? So there are the categories that we've added. We're just gonna add to for the sake of this demonstration.
Phoenix: So now we need to add a few expenses.
Phoenix: So let's go ahead and try to double tap on one of these categories and see if that's how you add an expense.
Phoenix: I don't know. I'm not
Phoenix: specific. But okay. So let's say, we went to the store and we spent
Phoenix: $150.
Phoenix: I'm just one with jocke.
Phoenix: with the specific
Phoenix: resistance. This position?
Phoenix: Well.
Phoenix: I'm not seeing how to add an expense here. So let's go back to
Phoenix: the screen we were on before this I had a final argument. Okay, let's try going back to the main menu. I just don't, really.
Phoenix: That's fine. Sorry schedule one.
Yeah, I'm sorry I'm not.
Phoenix: I'll even know this. and that's been better. Let's try going back up to the top.
Phoenix: It didn't go back up to the top like I wanted it to. Let's doublet up on months expenses.
Phoenix: Okay? Awesome
Phoenix: for me.
Phoenix: Okay, sorry.
Phoenix: Okay. Now, we're going to try to double tap on this food category. Okay.
Phoenix: Yup.
Phoenix: that doesn't appear to have brought anything up. Let's try clicking on a different part of this category.
Phoenix: You're like, sorry. This is my fault.
Phoenix: You'll get your responsibility specific budget
Phoenix: which are fun journal, Mr. Funnell.
Phoenix: But pause
Phoenix: apologies for the pause. I needed to get some brief clarifications on the task instructions.
Phoenix: So we're just going to go ahead and continue with where we left off. Trying to add some expenses.
Phoenix: So I'm going to continue to explore this screen.
Phoenix: So you've got
Phoenix: your expenses this month's expenses and food.
Phoenix: and I feel like this would be where I would add my expenses. But I'm not noticing a place to add them. So let me maybe try double tapping on
Phoenix: some of these options, maybe where it says food
Phoenix: that didn't do anything.
Phoenix: We'll try your expenses.
Phoenix: Okay. So we've tried double tapping on all the options, and it hasn't done anything. So let's go back. I know it was.
Phoenix: You're not. You're done bye.
Phoenix: Maybe I need. I don't know if I I'll try adjusting the slider and see what that does.
Phoenix: You're locked in. Tense, sir.
Bye? Bye.
Phoenix: no, no, sorry.
Phoenix: so I can see that there's a slider, and it's changing. But I have absolutely no idea what it does, because it it doesn't say what it does. It just says. 5%, 10%.
Phoenix: But I'm not quite sure what's happening. So I'm gonna go ahead and explore a little bit more and see if we can find a different way to add some expenses.
Phoenix: Morning, we're just fine.
Phoenix: Let's see what's in more options.
Bye-bye.
Phoenix: I don't feel like.
Phoenix: So those aren't what we need yet. Let's go back.
Phoenix: We'll try going back to the main menu, and let's just look at all the options that are present in the menu.
Phoenix: One of the
Phoenix: let's see what happens if we
Phoenix: double tap on budget plans. Okay? No problem.
Phoenix: Just 1%. I'm looking at like that.
Phoenix: Okay, so I don't. That doesn't appear to be where we can add expenses, either. Let's go back to the main menu.
Phoenix: Okay, okay.
Phoenix: bye, bye.
it's beneficial.
Phoenix: Okay, that's it.
Phoenix: I mean, that's another. Let's see. we've looked around a little bit in months expenses. Let's try one more thing. Okay? Awesome
Phoenix: morning. This one.
Phoenix: Okay, let's try double tapping on food and see if it brings up a list of options.
Phoenix: I am not noticing any options. Let me continue to explore the screen a little bit to see if maybe there's anything I miss.
Phoenix: Okay, sorry. Do you worry your first time?
Phoenix: One but
specific.
Phoenix: Okay. you're just
Phoenix: so I tried clicking on the the dollar amount. Double tapping. I apologize. And it it still brought me back to this screen where I can't enter anything. So let's go back.
Okay, no. Worries
Phoenix: continue to explore the screen.
Phoenix: Well, there's an ad expense button. Let's try this one.
Awesome.
Phoenix: Okay, that is much more self-explanatory. I was thinking you had to
Phoenix: get to a category first, and then you could add your expenses.
Phoenix: So and I really don't think that that's an accessibility issue. I just think that you know, a user guide would be helpful just to say.
Phoenix: when you're on your list of categories. There's a
Phoenix: add button at the bottom that will take you to where you had your expenses. And honestly, some of this was my fault. I should have explored the screen a little further, but I didn't. I just assumed it would be in the
Phoenix: I would double tap on a category, and that's how you would add it. So let's go ahead and try to add an expense here.
Phoenix: We know we want the
Phoenix: food category. So let's explore this whole screen before I make any decisions
Phoenix: enter the loss enterprise.
Phoenix: We're not fine.
Phoenix: Senator. Under the
Phoenix: apologies I had to sneeze. so we appear to be in some sort of calendar.
Phoenix: everything awesome.
Phoenix: so
Phoenix: navigating to the bottom of the screen, and see if that takes us past this calendar.
Phoenix: 100 people working
Phoenix: well, jingo, all the way to the bottom, but it did scroll significantly down the calendar. So let's continue to explore.
Phoenix: Let me go back to the top and let's have a little look now that we've explored the whole screen.
Phoenix: everything 33, 10.
Phoenix: And so there are 2. Apologize. There are 2 boxes that say, enter info this first one. It did eventually say
Phoenix: that it was the food category. So let's go to the right and see if this one has a description with it as well
Phoenix: does not so let's double tap on it, and just see what it brings up, because I can see that there are 10 characters allowed in it
so much. Thank you.
Phoenix: but I do not know what I'm supposed to put here. I don't know if it's supposed to be a description of what I purchased, or if it's where you put the amount of money that you spent, let me explore a little bit more to see if there's a separate category for the money. You spent
Phoenix: everything possible. Okay, awesome.
Phoenix: So all of these boxes are unlabeled.
Phoenix:  so that means that as a screen reader user. I do not know what is supposed to go in them. I can make my best guess, and we can see if that is or is not correct.
and we'll just try that since the first one takes 10 characters.
Phoenix: I'll just assume
Phoenix: that I'll put in a vague description of what was in here. So let's say we went to Walmart. I'll write Walmart in this box
Phoenix: today. Thank you absolutely.
Phoenix: Delete. L.
Thank you.
Tiktok.
Phoenix: Okay, let's look at the next box. But it wasn't
Phoenix: okay. Awesome.
Phoenix: Let's double tap on this and see what it does. Okay? So it looks like, this is where we're going to say how much we spent. So I said we would say, we spent 1 50.
Phoenix: So let's do one 5.
Phoenix: See? You?
Phoenix: Hospital. Okay?
Phoenix: Now, let's pick a date.
Okay.
Phoenix: don't work. Okay. But you said.
be a month fine.
Phoenix: Hold up, Gotcha Gotcha. We'll just say that we went there yesterday.
Phoenix: Monday, February 26.
Phoenix: Now let's see if there, I think there's an add transaction button.
Phoenix: Hold up.
Phoenix: Thank you. Thank you.
Your date on the work.
Phoenix: There we go. There we go.
Phoenix: double tap on add transaction.
Phoenix: You want to be invited.
Oh, I was supposed to add an income before I did this. so II only got confused on that, because when I added my categories, it said, add income, and for some reason
Phoenix: my mind thought we already added an income.
But I remember seeing add and come in more options. So let's look at that.
Phoenix: We're just one way. We're just one
Phoenix: like it was. Hang on.
Phoenix: I just we don't. I don't. We don't like
Phoenix: okay money amount? I don't.
Okay.
Phoenix: and I don't know if we're doing yearly or monthly. It would be helpful if it said, you know, annual income or monthly income. But I'm just for the sake of this exercise I'm going to assume it's monthly, so we'll say that we had a $6,000 income.
Phoenix: okay.
Phoenix: I just thought I got one
Phoenix: double tap on add income.
Phoenix: Now we will once again try to add the suspense.
Okay, awesome. I wasn't.
Phoenix: and it's already in food. Everything else.
Phoenix: We went to.
Phoenix: Speaker. If you want to. tapped on the wrong thing, let me go back.
Phoenix: Pause.
Phoenix: apologies for the pause. II just had some technical difficulties I had to work out. So let's go ahead and type in this screen. The name of this, the place where we shop, at which I said was Walmart. So let's do.
Phoenix: WA. Umhm
Phoenix: Jenny Oopsi
Phoenix: on Mute.
Phoenix: and I said we spent $150. So let's look for the next box.
Phoenix: Representative. Everything possible, everything possible. 1 50.
Alright.
Phoenix: And I said, we shop there yesterday.
Phoenix: Hold up 2 pump 2.
I'm gonna do nothing work.
Phoenix: and you're ready to stop my period.
Phoenix: 100, you know 101
Phoenix: double tap on add transaction. There we go, and II like the the little notification it gives when you have completed the transaction.
When you've added the transaction, perhaps in the future I would be helpful to make it shorter, and just say transaction added.
Phoenix: but for the sake of time. we're just going to add only one expense to this. and let's now we'll move on.
Phoenix: We're going to edit one of our categories.
we'll just change the budget. So let's go
Phoenix: back to the main menu.
Phoenix: We'll double top on budget categories.
Phoenix: 1 point we're just one morning, Buddy.
Phoenix: Bye, bye.
Phoenix: we'll change our food expense.
Phoenix: Ouch, ouch!
Phoenix: Let's go back, cause I didn't do it. Like we'll double tap and hold. See if that brings it up.
Phoenix: But if it did not, let's try more options. Okay.
Phoenix: just bye.
Phoenix: Honest, with journal.
Phoenix: the clock
Phoenix: morning. Let's see. Okay.
Phoenix: okay, there we go
Phoenix: at this point. Yes. But last, but
we're gonna change this to
Phoenix: $300.
Phoenix: I don't know. And but we don't do
done.
Phoenix: You know your test fun
Phoenix: and add income
Phoenix: under the resource.
Phoenix: Okay, now, let's create a budget plan.
Phoenix: Point 1 point.
Phoenix: Let's look under budget plans and see if that's where it's at.
Phoenix: Okay?
Phoenix: Ouch.
Phoenix: okay.
Phoenix: I am not seeing the option. Let's look under more options, and that's brought us back.
Phoenix: I apologize. It looks like the more options doesn't change from screen to screen. So we know to stop checking. There, let's go back.
Phoenix: Joel. Welcome!
Phoenix: Let's look at the main menu.
Phoenix: I'm not. Just let me get another.
Phoenix: I'm fine. I think I'll just
Phoenix: check my hand.
Phoenix: Just continue to explore this a little bit more
Phoenix: you won't have.
Phoenix: You're walking. You're walking up. you wanna give me a long time one time.
Phoenix: Bye. Bye.
Phoenix: Ouch! Ouch!
Okay, there we go. So the create a plan. Button is unlabeled. And unfortunately it was right next to my zoom controls. So I thought it was part of that so obviously in the future the best
Phoenix: it. It would be advisable to add a create plan, label, or something to this button. Let's look at creating this plan
Phoenix: awesome.
Phoenix: We're just gonna put the number one.
Phoenix: Mr. Hoffman Hendell
Phoenix: so much left we can put none at that.
Phoenix: I don't know
Phoenix: your test. One test.
Phoenix: Okay? So we'll say
Phoenix: we'll just put the plans. Budget at 6,000, because that's our monthly income.
Phoenix: Just fine.
Okay, hold on. Don't worry.
Phoenix: Sorry. Sometimes I have a difficult time finding the 0. There we go. Okay. Nothing awesome.
Phoenix: That's fine fun.
Phoenix: Okay, we'll give it a deadline date
Phoenix: for some day next month in March. Let's say, done so that this keyboard box goes away.
Phoenix: Next month
Phoenix: we'll do March sixth. Okay, number 4.
Phoenix: Double tap on. Add plan.
Phoenix: Alright. Now let's look at the analysis results. So we'll go back to the main menu.
Phoenix: Let's look at budget analysis.
Phoenix: Okay, no. But rob is fine. 100,000 and tragic and dark, doesn't
Phoenix: which? So there's a lot about this that is not accessible. It it doesn't tell you.
Phoenix: I mean it really doesn't break down the individual elements of the chart. So like, for example, let's look at it together.
Phoenix: Okay.
Phoenix: so this I don't understand. The one points thing, the min value and the Max value are both 150, and that's probably because I only added 1 $150 expense to this.
but it's not presented in a clear
Phoenix: category like in in clear information. You know, you spent this amount of money this month.
Phoenix: and like, don't talk like
Phoenix: which.
Phoenix: So then there's food and bills and food and 0 0. I don't know what any of those are. I apologize. It started talking by itself.
So I don't know what those expenses are.
Phoenix: I, don't they? So some more descriptive labels will be helpful for this chart. Let's go back to the main menu. Okay.
Phoenix: let's look at the monthly expenses of that analysis.
Phoenix: Just fine. Thank you.
Phoenix: I mean, does. And this just simply says nothing it it says Web View.
Phoenix: but it doesn't give you any kind of indication of what's in this web view. So I would say, overall this app.
You can definitely tell that it
Phoenix: it appears to be in a prototype stage, but it's coming along very nicely. A few more descriptive labels on the
Phoenix: titles of text fields would be helpful. There is absolutely no information provided in the
Phoenix: monthly analysis.
Phoenix: I believe, is the one that we're on right now. So some descriptors for the charts, or I'm not certain what it visually shows.
Phoenix: And then the the
Phoenix: budget analysis. It has similar problems. There are. There's a little bit of data that's presented, but it's not clearly able to be interpreted.
Phoenix: But I believe that this app is well on its way. It, I think in a few months time it could be more accessible.
Phoenix: With all of that being said, I apologize that this video took longer than it should have. I was trying to familiarize myself with the app, and I do hope that my
Phoenix: test has been helpful, and thank you so much for watching.